hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and I'm shooting this quick video
because I want to talk about an anomaly
that occurs every once in a while in the
order flow and it's something that you
could look for if you use a volume
footprint chart now point of control or
as some people refer to it in a bar the
co teeth equipment or Traders
um but I use the term point of control
is the price level on the bar with the
most volume and it's the volume taken at
both the bid side and the offer side for
a price level and in a footprint chart
it's usually highlighted with a sort of
grayish box around that price level
now
every bar has a point of control okay
because obviously there's volume in
every bar and you know it's sort of
depending on where it comes in in the
bar does have a a slight impact in how
the market is going to react now one of
the interesting things is you know point
of control since it's volume related you
know the most volume when you start to
have several lined up at the same price
level you know consecutive bars whether
it's you know a time-based chart like
every you know a one minute bar and you
start to have two or three lined up one
right after the other at the exact same
level it's telling you that that's an
area where
there's a lot of volume going through
and again if you're using a volume based
chart you're also going to see it if
you're using a tick based chart you're
also going to see it and what's
interesting is when you have them lined
up like this right here's two one two
and then the market trades away from it
it's often uh worth you know sort of
making a mark on your chart in case the
market comes back to that level you know
it could give you an a nice uh entry
price okay so you can see here the
market was trading back and forth this
was around uh what is that 4027 area you
got the two-pointed controls right at
the same level Market sold off
then started working its way back up
right up here
right to that level rotate it around
there for a few minutes and then sold
off again now there's two pointed
controls lined up one right after the
other right down here
but then the market just continued to
trade at that price for the next several
minutes that's not what I would like to
look for I would like to look for
um you know where the market moves away
from those two pointed controls
you know another example
um you know what is this this is crude
oil okay now
let's get the crosshairs here there were
a couple pointed controls right here one
two lined up now what's interesting in
this crude chart today is you know
there's you know there's two here
there's another one here there's another
one here so basically you got three here
you know that's what Market generated
information is it acts as support but
when I see you know a couple prices like
this and the market rallies up I'm
always going to be looking to see if the
Market's going to come back down to it
and look at this it came right back down
to this 8700 level again you put in
another point of control right at that
level rallied back up in that same bar
it went from 87 all the way up to 87
what is that 34 even came back down
within a tick here or actually that is
back down to 87 and then you know
rallied up into back up again into the
87 40s now you know I wish I could say
that this was
um you know the perfect setup that it's
always going to be like that but it's
not okay there are times where it works
beautifully like this there's times
where it doesn't it just fails and
that's why you know obviously you could
put a stop in but if you could have a
level right imagine that right you have
this level that it was formed right in
here at 906 907 this morning
Market rallies up comes right back down
to it gets literally to that tick one
tick two ticks through it and bounces
another 30 ticks you know if you're just
using you know a five point stop
tick stop
um you know you can give you a nice low
risk entry
so I hope you found this useful if you
like this video I'm hoping to make more
in the future make sure you subscribe to
my channel hit the like button so I know
you're enjoying this content then leave
a comment below so thanks guys and I'll
see you guys on the next video